the movie business is expected to lose
up to 17 billion dollars I know man the
clitoris vacuum is ruining everything
restaurants bars gyms all theaters are
closing down wait what did you call it
oh yeah we can't say the actual word
that everybody around the world is
talking about every single second of the
day or else YouTube will get our video D
monetized so I had to call it something
else wouldn't calling it that C words
still get us to monetize oh man we just
can't catch a break
Black Widow delayed Idris Elba tested
positive black Superman every movie is
coming out on V oh yeah yeah Jared Leto
has apparently just learned about the
corona virus yup he's on this season's
big brother my girlfriend rescued a
squirrel fell out of a tree family
unfortunately didn't make it she brought
this little guy home I call him Rick
Rick little Ricky and that's exactly why
I call him Rick really cuz he's a
survivor oh you're a survivor he's been
the best he's so cute and he's getting
so much energy I don't know if we're
gonna keep him considering we got a
bunch of cats but I wanted to just share
him with you guys while I can he's gonna
distract me the whole time this is gonna
be the most unprofessional video you've
ever seen let's talk about it all right
first story on the agenda black widow
has been delayed officially how dare you
mess Marvel with Marvel and try not to
be too loud now there's a squirrel right
we all kind of saw this coming you know
yeah I mean the biggest I think question
mark was just if it's about here they've
done all of their advertising final
trailer and so yeah that was the big one
everybody was waiting on I was surprised
when they put out a final trailer well
they're pretty so much speculation that
it would get delayed that was after no
time to die got pushback right yeah I
think so it's not surprising it's a
bummer because Black Widow already took
forever to get off the ground so that's
the sad part about it but you know it's
for the best at this point I know we all
love our marvel
we can wait we can wait again but like a
whole bunch of movies have been shutting
down production as they should be social
distancing is important I know we
sometimes make our jokes because we're
trying to bring some levity to the
situation and a slight sense of escapism
like I like to escape a little Ricky
right here a whole bunch of movies have
shut down production as they should
that man has they have at least then a
couple weeks shutdown shang-chi director
did not test positive but they're still
holding off rightfully so James Cameron
is lying and making up the excuse of
this pandemic saying that's why they're
not shooting it right now whatever James
Cameron it's been delayed for years all
right
don't don't just use this as your
scapegoat to joking it was really in
production think they ready start
filming or something yeah oh yeah
they're into production on like three of
those movies and then there was a point
where the theaters we got this repartee
MCA list and they were saying that okay
we're only allowing fifty percent of
people to sit in the theaters but
officially Regal Cinemas and AMC
theaters have shut down yet all their
theaters for the next few weeks video on
demand is looking rather interesting
right now I think this is gonna be a
crucial moment for the future of how we
see movies not to say the theaters will
go away but you know this is kind of a
for a period of trial for releasing big
new release films on video on demand and
seeing how people respond to that and
granted you know everyone is at home
more than usual so I don't know if this
will indicate what the true future of
consistent new release VOD will be but
it's gonna be interesting to watch that
because actually weirdly cost more
especially if you're someone who has an
a-list membership one of those kind of
reward programs with a theater chain
it's actually gonna cost you more
because the video on demand like 20
bucks or something like that and they're
probably they might even raise the
prices I don't know the full extent of
it but they might raise the prices just
because they're trying to compensate for
the fact that they're not in the
theaters theoretically you're not gonna
get one charge per person exactly you
could have a group people doubling up or
yeah yeah all the friends together
because it's probably not now 10 ppm
less together the hunt and New Mutants
are like the most funny situations to me
out of this whole thing because the hunt
got delayed for its reasoning and then
this happens and now you go to the
theatres to watch it New Mutants you
know what a lot of people are saying
just put
video-on-demand at this point just do it
a scintillate so much I'm not gonna go
into that corner no at this point I'm
like no keep fighting now did you wait
so the feeders they're open again and
you put that damn thing in the theaters
you burned it as everyone who's earned
it it's that damn movie right they don't
get your reshoots you've been patient
yeah nobody knows what to expect from
you you least deserve a real I don't
care if it comes out in it god-awful
you deserved it you earned it you have
long enough you brought up an
interesting point about video-on-demand
they might see more profit yeah they
might go maybe this is maybe we should
just start doing more movies on video on
demand like when this is all over and
that that's kind of the thing that has
me curious because Netflix already
opened up this module for you it's a
Netflix original but we'll put in the
theaters for a few weeks and now they
might get big movies or like oh this
might actually just do better in the
video on-demand platform not even like
streaming like video like you have yet
rented this might do better there then
actually in the theaters well then that
makes you wonder further how much
that'll change budgets because you know
we often bulk about the fact that the
mid-range twenty to sixty million dollar
movie is shrinking in the marketplace in
favor of either a hundred million or a
hundred thousand or a million if I
wonder if a stronger shift or a stronger
allocation of films between theaters and
VOD might open it back up for that range
of films because there's less to make
back arguably so true Jon would be
interesting they all so true Ricky
doesn't even know he's like Jared Leto
and then there are movies too that are
supposed to be getting earlier releases
I think frozen to is one of them on
Disney Plus I'm pretty sure Harley Quinn
the birds of prey whatever it's called
live die repeat it's coming out earlier
now to uh least I know they've been
pushing for it that's the one I'm most
excited yeah VOD because I actually
wanna watch it again and I feel like
people might actually give it a chance
now maybe that'll make up for some of it
so I haven't even read this story yet
here was my reaction when I was
searching for movie news today with John
in the corner cheer Leto has the
coronavirus Oh what Morbius the guy who
specializes in blood testing and stuff
really doesn't know about the
coronavirus and maybe this is viral
market Andrew Morris I haven't read this
yet apparently he posted this on his
Instagram and Twitter Wow twelve days
ago I began a silent notes assessment
I'm gonna take every day but I literally
meditate for like 15 to 20 minutes every
day well you know this man already runs
like an island experience where he
dresses in white and leather meditates
with fans of 30 Seconds to Mars I'm
flashing right to Topher Grace in that
episode of black were totally isolated
no phone no communication etc we had no
idea what was happening outside the
facility walked outside yesterday into a
very difficult world one that's been
changed forever mind-blowing to say the
least I'm getting messages from friends
and family all around the globe and
catching up on what's going on hope you
and yours are okay some positive energy
to all stay inside stay safe well sounds
like he's alright probably doing the
best out of all the famous people he's
been in the desert for two weeks which
means you know the heat like Trump says
I'm surrounding your front heel boa this
story complete just want to know form
you guys about Jared Leto status the
thing is like the one that really scared
me is Idris Elba I watched the video of
it or cell but it's such a bummer I
think he'll be okay I feel I have faith
he'll be okay you got to keep in mind
them yeah they're been deaths around the
world most people who have been
diagnosed with this have been able to
beat it a lot of the cases I think
majority of them are actually mild to
moderate that's what I've heard yeah I
mean it seems like with any pandemic I
mean obviously you need to be vigilant
stay safe but it seems like the most
affected groups are always the elderly
the very young and anybody who has a
chronic condition or a pre-existing you
yes you know we do know a couple people
who don't like well that are friends of
ours who don't live here in California
but one believes they have it and
another one it definitely has it pretty
scary times right now and the thing with
that would inter-cell but was talking
about I think is it a really important
one because a lot of the time people are
looking for symptoms and he was
explaining that he doesn't have any
symptoms she just thought he should get
tested because he came in contact with
someone and I just goes to show you that
social distancing is important right now
he's totally peeing in my hand you're so
cute for peace means your guys can't see
it is clear liquid but he's
what do they do good he's hydrated thank
you for distracting from a serious story
there this is this is how every movie
news [ __ ] should go you can't you can't
adopt Rick to anybody it just makes
sense that if people are not taking
action to properly do social distancing
something it's gonna happen everything
they got to enforce the quarantine rules
everything like that it's like they
should they're probably gonna do it
regardless because it's a wise thing to
do no you do have to regularly wash your
hands I know it's a hassle but it's a
simple discipline it really is a simple
discipline sanitizer on hand exactly I
can pay $100 to get a bottle you gotta
be safe there's a reason there haven't
been any guests really coming around
John and I we still slap each other on
the ass when we show up but it's not a
handshake no yeah then we wash our hands
and our asses out just to be sanitary in
yourself oh you're one of the coolest
people in the world working the business
today
roomie I hope I hope you'll be okay I
have a lot of faith you'll be all right
if you are someone who has been tested
positive I sincerely wish you the best
during this time as harsh as it is maybe
share your experience in any way that
you can just so that people know whether
they're kind of looking at because I
think - there's a lot of hysteria out
there and I think it does help when
people who have tested positive you know
talk about it and share the experience
Jared Leto I hope your mind is clear
yeah we can still do videos fortunately
we're very fortunate to have you guys
here's that's to allow us to do work
from in-home so genuinely appreciate
everyone who's here do what you can to
keep yourself educated same time be
cautious
be safe every once in a while find a
form of escapism get your mind off
things
certainly helps now go wash your hands
before you do that subscribe you the
rejects click that notification bell
Paulson Stardust will be posting
regularly there in the meantime say bye
Rick Rick needs an insta to say bye look
at you look at you going buddy cutest
yeah he likes to do is curl up and stuff
yeah we got a whole tank in a whole set
up he was so sick and quiet and then
mainly Olivia has been saving this
little guy look dude all this stuff and
I just go in and go let me play with
on camera you take care of all the
shopping to get reciprocal help do the
research on what nutrients he needs to
survive and I'll play with